El Vaticano confirmó que el funeral de
Benedicto 16 se llevará a cabo el
próximo jueves 5 de enero la última
voluntad del Papa emérito fue que su
funeral fuera lo más sencillo posible la
ceremonia en la plaza de San Pedro será
presidida por el Papa Francisco se trata
de un ritual inédito ya que es la
primera vez en más de 600 años que un
Papa emérito retirado muere mientras que
ya hay otro papá a cargo gobernando la
Iglesia Católica a partir del próximo
lunes el cuerpo del Papa emérito será
expuesto en la Basílica de San Pedro
para que los fieles que lo deseen puedan
darle un último adiós a Benedicto 16 un
pontífice que será recordado como un
tradicionalista conservador en temas
como el aborto la homosexualidad o la
eutanasia fue un gran teólogo un gran
predicador pero también su papado estuvo
marcado por polémicas por declaraciones
como cuando cuestionó el uso del
preservativo o escándalos como el
conocido como El batilix la una fuga de
documentos filtrados a la prensa por su
mayordomo personal albatilice muchos le
atribuyeron la causa de su renuncia sin
embargo Benedicto siempre reiteró que
renunció porque sintió que no tenía las
fuerzas físicas para seguir gobernando a
la iglesia católica fuerzas físicas que
definitivamente lo abandonaron este 31
de diciembre cuando murió a las 9 y 34
de la mañana en el Vaticano